[Music]
so the city of new york is going to
begin offering 100
to incentivize covet vaccines for kids
ages 5 to 11.
nazi germany
who are they giving the money to
everything they're giving it to the
families they need to give it to the
kids if they're going to shoot up the
kids they need to give a hundred dollars
to the kids what's wrong where does this
happen
in new york wait who they pay the money
to
their parents kids 100 bucks yeah well
like the fan i can assume it goes to the
family it's just that feels crazy
that's so weird you're getting [ __ ]
paid to get vaccinated no you're getting
paid to get your kids vaccinated that
feels so shady for somebody
300 bucks yeah
why does that feel so shady because
because it's shady for real because
that's why i feel shady look i'm all for
vaccines and [ __ ] but [ __ ] dude that
seems just very weird and everybody like
the whole stack is where's your vaccine
hold on
show me the hole right there okay but
anyways with the whole government trying
to push [ __ ] the vaccines it does
feel very weird
and the fact that they're like giving
dangling prizes in front of you and all
that and it's like what the hell is
happening but not only that like
mandating it and making everyone do it
that's the weird [ __ ] cause i'm
vaccinated too and i'm like i just i
it's like [ __ ] i had to do it because
also like i'm tired of paying like 120
bucks every time i go to hawaii what
incentives did you get did you get any
prizes i wish i should have waited
i wanted to get a [ __ ] lollipop at
least i didn't get none of that [ __ ]
dude i just got a sore arm dude yeah
damn man i want a hundred dollars of
good rapport no no no close to your mom
yeah
she gets it missed weren't they doing a
lottery at some point too yeah money
money yeah the raffle dude what was it
going for the cal state delay [ __ ]
crazy
it was like laker tickets it was at some
point there was marijuana being
distributed crazy like ham yeah he's
already got like 12 vaccines i got a
bunch dude hey it's krispy kreme giving
out donuts and [ __ ]
i'm never getting it yeah i still want
donuts right now if they give out
bitcoins i'll get vaccine like 16. same
bro i'll get i'll get every vac
everything
i'll do it yeah a lot more just gotta go
to el salvador dude
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] that's crazy
hundred dollars that's it i mean scrap
them just the idea of it just here we're
gonna give you money to do this thing
you know what about all the p all the
people that don't vax their kids right
do they get paid
as uh incentive to like
vax your kids for [ __ ] measles or
whatever the true anti-vaxxers like
unless measles was popping the way it
goes cause like you know all
all babies get shots we all get shot
we've all had shots he's just popping
again
popping off yo you hear about the music
popping boys what's up
i mean
i would do it for the
money [ __ ] dude it's like man this is
hella weird but [ __ ] it's time to get my
kid vaccinated
well i don't even know enough about the
science to to make a comment on it
because like if it's gonna [ __ ]
destroy me in like three years or
whatever like i don't [ __ ] know you
know but you can't force them to do that
yeah here's the thing though if you take
a hundred dollars and put in a sheep
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's over
yeah
it's three years i mean like what two
years ago if you put in the sheaves
right like right now it's too late it's
totally no no it's never too late you
just hold it hold a little bit it's
gonna pump back up so 20 years from now
it's gonna be [ __ ] two dollars yeah
damn
well isn't it like everybody who got
like 30 in bitcoin in el salvador now at
like 65 bucks in value or something like
that right something like that so it's
kind of like and that was like the whole
country would download their wallet so
again [ __ ] the cash will you give me
fifty dollars in bitcoin i'll get i'll
find kids yeah oh that sounds weird oh
fine kids take it back damn bro i would
start a kenja's orphanage oh
is that next to the brand i'll be like
look we have 20 000 kids here
pay up government yep let's go that's 20
g's bitcoin by the way that's going to
cost
this facility costs way more than that i
don't know what i'm doing as a business
person
but uh yeah
we're going to break even please pick
maybe the fingers crossed i think the
scary part is the mandated part because
did you guys see like how like uh back
in the 50s the doctors were telling
pregnant women that they should smoke
and it's good for them so a lot of the
time but it was though back then exactly
right so everything when you when you
view
time and like that slice of life without
any other context
it's really hard to make any decision
that we'll know if it's right or wrong
so you have to give people time to think
about it yeah and so when they're like
you only have this window to make the
right decision it feels like very used
car sales mini like if you leave this
deal is off the table yeah so i think
that if it says if it's like getting the
flu shot right where people get it by
choice
it's so different like i don't know it's
it's weird it's not like the black
plague where it's like people are
dropping on the streets um and i get you
know getting a vaccine for things like
that
but it's like ah that's [ __ ] weird
it's just it's just incentivizing it is
even more weird aren't people like loki
dropping on the streets isn't that like
the problem no i don't like the black
death dude i mean yeah i'm not like
one of the worst players
40th century
yes 99 survival rate
and then uh i think they brought like an
aircraft carrier to be hospital best
because they thought it was gonna
overflow but then they never used it
yeah so it's it's not but then also too
like my but one of my clients he's a
nurse at a hospital and they said they
had to
create a whole another wing for all
these people that young people all
different ages who got coveted and who
just got jacked up from it they have no
idea why it's all varying different uh
issues issues varying issues within that
some people exactly [ __ ] and then they
need transplants so there's a whole
separate wing that they started to be
able to
accommodate and help those people so
then that's another argument too it's
like okay if you get the vaccine will
you be more protected from these types
of issues because it is so random it is
so new nobody really knows so it is a
very complex issue in that way and like
somebody like me i got covered and i
actually got healthier afterwards
than i've ever been dick dude i felt
good that old dick
i felt way good
colvin made me healthier cnn says steve
green says coleman made him healthier it
cleared my skin up
said green
as he smiled
yeah so i think that tough part too the
tough part is now if they want the
parents to make their kids get
vaccinated right that's the mandate but
even at a regular hospital like when
tycho was born they go hey do you want
them to get all the vaccines measles
polio whatever i'm like of course you're
gonna give me but it's still it's still
my choice though you know
that's the important thing yeah because
if we said no then they'd be like all
right cool we're not going to come and
give them all these shots yeah but now
they're like
it's just treating it completely
different for kovitz specifically
but if it wasn't so politicized if it
wasn't so that's the issue right yeah if
it wasn't so politicized if it wasn't so
like
we're not sure the integrity behind it
especially with fauci and everyone it's
it's like he's he's supposed to be the
head of this and now it's coming out
where a lot of people are just like
roasting his ass for catching him lying
and all this stuff right oh you guys get
his book yet are you guys gonna get it
okay i'm gonna get it signed i'm gonna
get an audio book
but you're ready at that time you can
catch me up on what did you guys hear
about the beagle story the what the
fouchy beagles story no oh bro they had
a
i don't know part of what they funded
for the nih was a a program where they
they put beagles they cut their um
vocal cords
and they they
basically had them laying down with like
these these nets over their heads and
they had fruit flies
in there eating their eyeballs
and that was like one of the things that
they were researching what were they
trying to get out of it [ __ ] no idea
bro but it's just one of those things
that was in the nih um um [ __ ] ledger
where everyone's looking at like what
they funded and like there's pictures of
it and [ __ ] it's pretty wild so
basically he was one of the one of the
big controversies is he was aware of the
virus and not everything and he was
lying to the american public on top of
that he was saying like how masks are
effective it's not effective he's going
back and forth when he knew about the
science and the evidence he withheld
that information from the public when he
was doing those was that was that was
that his fault or was he like oh yeah he
knew the information he knew he knew
otherwise and he said later that he's
kind of a snake bro well and he he said
later that he did it to make sure that
um hospitals could get access to masks
he didn't want to run on masks but bro
you're still lying to people and if you
if they're so effective that's what
makes people so leery of i mean yeah he
could have just told the american public
look hospitals need these people uh ease
or whatever
rat masks uh guards whatever
uh we need them for the hospitals first
don't [ __ ] hoard it like that's what
he should have little cuck-ass [ __ ]
go you have a look what we do to toilet
paper so so we should get lied to and
i'm like bro you want you're begging to
get lied to really is that what you want
all right cool yeah but that so that's
that's just like a piece of it right but
then when there's so much misinformation
from our own government and also
we know that there's a lot of money
that's being kind of passed around
during the situation with the
pharmaceutical industry and the deals
that are happening behind the closed
doors now everyone's like
well i can't trust this 100 because
there's so many holes
and and there are people that blindly
believe in they're like just [ __ ] do
it so i could get it over with but i'm
just like how
i wish i could have the faith that i
want with with our government and our
medical industry but we can't
and this is what makes it dangerous it's
like do we blindly follow into these
situations when they don't have our best
interest and society's best interest if
everyone's money motivated or
politically motivated and all they care
about there's campaigns or whatever they
don't care about us they care about them
winning so i'm like
why would i put this vaccine in my body
because i don't even know if they even
checked it right i think that's the
issue from a lot of people at least i
know that are like i don't want to
[ __ ] do this is anybody getting hyped
for the fountain documentary coming up
yeah dude i'm super hyped dude that one
trashing him or is that one more oh it's
loving him dude they're they're sucking
his dick with no teeth really so it's
all pro fouchy
counter balance it i saw wait isn't
there one that's already out it's like
rotten tomatoes it's like only like 10
or something oh my god well because it
people are pissed because they they're
they don't trust voucher but then the
media is putting him up on a pedestal
saying like he's like a guy like like
all the stuff you just talked about is
rarely being touched on in the big media
that's the weird thing right on youtube
channel yeah and breaking points like
sagar yeah and what's crazy is that
we're starting to see openly the
collusion between
[ __ ] media traditional media [ __ ]
big pharma you know all these
corporations that work together with the
government and how it's kind of
deceiving the public and then people are
like well i don't wanna i'm not sure if
i'm ready to
just blindly believe what you guys say
anymore because they don't even follow
their own rules when they go like hey
everyone you have to wear this
they put it on as soon as they go see
their homie they take it off like
literally backstage and they're laughing
at us they're laughing at the citizens
about you know
all this [ __ ] stuff that we're
believing in but they're fooling us and
i'm like man that's kind of a [ __ ] up
relationship between the citizens and
the politicians
at the white house by the way
really
and that's [ __ ] weird that's weird
they want the rest of us to do it but
they don't [ __ ] do it i wonder what
their vaccination rate in the white
house is
out of curiosity what was it i do too
also joe rogan even just came out and
said that his doctor treated 200
congress people with ivormectin
horse glue or whatever
first pace
that is a [ __ ] glitch in the matrix
you know how like joe rogan just
recently called out that [ __ ] dog
then he went
[ __ ] did it again dude oh my god but
that's even funnier because he's just
they're just proving how [ __ ]
fraudulent they are what do you say when
he went back on cnn he was like he
basically framed the interview with joe
like it wasn't a real interview like oh
we're around [ __ ] we're joking around
and then even was like well you know i
know that the interview's not serious
you're all with joe rogan's comedian
yeah but then the next day anytime he
says something they're like joe rogan
said this and they take it for serious
you know oh and sanjay said that he felt
intimidated during the interview oh he
was bullied i would be more intimidated
by don lemon than joe rogan yeah don
lemon
dude
he doesn't blink that much did you ever
realize that i never even noticed that
yeah check watch next time you watch
them you should try the fruit fly
experiment on that
on that pair
to be honest like all of the fraudulent
collusion and stuff that i'm like not
surprised but when i hear about the
beagles i'm like what the [ __ ] yeah
that's crazy [ __ ] up
why did they have to choose cute ass
beagles
what dog would you choose purebred
beagle come on man no one wants to say
what other dog i'd say like the [ __ ]
dogs at the pound
i don't know bugs bro
i don't know you got beef against pugs
you